in the last example of the previous clip
we have observed that the initial state
of where the Markov chain starts can
matter and that in some cases the
influence of the initial State never
vanishes in the long run so when we
wanted to calculate the probability of
ending up in state one knowing that you
started instead one give you that
probability and if you started in state
three you had another long term
probability and in case you were started
in state two then you were equally
likely to add up and being in state one
or in state three we have said that this
was due to the fact that some states are
not accessible from some other states
our goal here is to make such a
statement more precise and formal in
order to do so we will classify the
states of a Markov chain in a transition
diagram into two types recurrent and
transient the state is set to be
recurrent if starting from that state no
matter where you go there is always a
path to come back a state is said to be
transient if it is not reckoned it means
that starting from that state there is
at least one place where you can go and
then there will be no path back to it
for example starting from state eight no
matter where you go there is always a
path back to eight so eight will be said
to be a recurrent state for the same
reason seven will also be a recurrent
state as well as six now what about five
from five the only state where you can
go to is five itself
so five is also a recurrent State let us
look now at a state lat state for from
for there is the possibility of a path
going through to then one and then going
to five from which there is no path back
to four so four cannot be a recurrent
State it is then called a transient
State for the same reason
starting from three there is the
possibility that after doing many
transition around here eventually you
will end up being in either two and then
go to six or you will be eventually be
in one and then go to five and from five
or from six
there will be no path back to three so
three is also a transient State and it
is clear that for the same reason one
will be a transient State and two will
also be a transient State
now if a state is transient like three
for one or two it means that it will be
visited only a finite number of times
and in the long run
the probability of being in a transient
State will converge to zero the
recurrent states of a Markov chain can
be grouped in different classes here in
this example we have to search classes
here this is one class
and here you have another class what is
so special about these classes well
within one class like for example in
this class all recurrent states have a
way to communicate between each other
but there is no communication between
recurrent states of different classes
from that recurrent state here you have
no communication with that recurrent
state here no communication in the sense
that there is no path joining that state
to that state or that state to that
state the existence of more than one
class of recurrent States like in this
example in a Markov chain will be the
telling sign that initial states will
matter in the chain it's pretty clear
here that if your markov chain starts in
state five you will never end up in
state six seven or eight and if you
start in one of the state six seven
eight you will never end up in state
five so depending on where you started
the long range priority of being
eventually in state six will not be the
same